berliner sportakrobaten zeigen ihr
können
mittendrin auch der 16-jährige arman
boyraz und seine jüngere schwester bilde
die einzigen deutsch türken in diesem
tonfall
die stolzen eltern legen wert auf gute
integration ihrer kinder ein überwiegend
von türken besuchter fußballverein etwa
wäre für sie nicht infrage gekommen
hinterher spendiert familie boyraz
türkische wassermelone
ihr motto dazu gehören und dennoch seine
türkischen wurzeln nicht vergessen damit
derzeit fühlen wir uns hier sehr wohl
eigentlich in berlin eigentlich wie zu
hause aber drüben auch also bei mir ist
leider bei beiden ländern bin ich so
fest verankert für zeit aber ich bin
mich in beiden ländern eigentlich sehr
wohl aber man ist hier geboren und hat
deshalb das recht auf die deutsche und
die türkische staatsbürgerschaft ihn
wurmt dass das nun wieder zur diskussion
steht für ihn heißt das entweder oder
deutsch oder türkisch
durch diesen beiden pässen verbinden
sich so gesagt die länder und dann baut
man auf brücken auf zwischen
verschiedenen kulturen und dadurch wie
soll ich sagen wird deutschland obwohl
es auch sehr multikulturell wird
vielleicht noch multikultureller doch im
deutschen wahlkampf wird die cdu wieder
für die sogenannte optionspflicht danach
müsste sich armand spätestens mit 24
jahren für einen der beiden pässe
entscheiden eine politische kehrtwende
und reaktionen auf die politik des
türkischen staatspräsidenten erdogan
denn der macht hierfür sich wahlkampf
bei den rund 1,4 millionen deutsch
türken und gibt wahlempfehlungen für die
deutschen bundestags und das ist eben
ein grund dafür warum
viele viele kinderlose
das kann und so eine einige schulen
kultur und zu lebensmut nicht schon
ausgegeben
susanne enttäuschend findet man auch
nebenan bei der liberalen
oppositionspartei fdp keine überzeugten
freunde der doppelten staatsbürgerschaft
das ist ihre partei dazu
[Musik]
was haben dann nach ihm wieder wieder
rechnen haben wir irgendwann
wenn die leute halt wirklich leben muss
irgendwann halt meine endgültige
entscheidung
finden sie es richtig dass dieses recht
nur von der türkei in turm wird aber
anderen europäischen ländern nicht auch
nichts dafür nur türkisch nur deutsch
oder beides in der familie bei das ist
alles vertreten doch einfach ist das
nicht während die kinder mit beiden
staatsangehörigkeiten aufwachsen tun
sich die eltern mit einer entscheidung
schwer
wenn wir jetzt an unserer sagen herr
türkische staatsbürgerschaft dann auch
abgeben würden würden wir auch dort dann
diskriminiert dh dann was wollt ihr dann
deutsch türken ihr habt nicht mal
türkischer staatsbürgerschaft versucht
ihr dann so nach dem motto man will in
seiner heimatstadt berlin bleiben aber
der türkische pass ist für ihn so etwas
wie die brücke in die heimat seiner
eltern
ich hoffe dass es nicht so weit kommt
und ich zu solch einer wahl gestellt
werden muss und deswegen natürlich würde
ich also zum deutschen tendieren aber
das würde schon im herzen weh tun was
armen ärgert ist dass auch gut
integrierte türkische jugendliche wie er
durch den streit zwischen berlin und
ankara einen teil ihrer identität
verlieren könnten